Netflix continues to be a beacon of light
for serialized genre fiction, as they are
now readying new seasons of hit series like
Stranger Things and The Umbrella Academy,
and adding explosive new treats on a near
weekly basis.
For those on the lookout for a fresh fantasy
offering, Netflix's latest is a live-action
drama based on a beloved animated series.
Indeed, the Nickelodeon series which inspired
this new show is Winx Club, which follows
the adventures of five gifted teen fairies
who attend a magical boarding school and fight
evildoers in the magical realm of Otherworld.
However, fans of Winx Club should know that
Netflix's Fate: The Winx Saga is a very different
beast than its more kid-friendly inspiration.
Perhaps taking a cue from the recent successes
of adult-oriented teen dramas like Riverdale
and Chilling Adventures of Sabrina, the new
Netflix venture delivers a wild mix of bombastic
action, brooding teen angst, and saucy romance,
along with an inspiring journey of self-discovery.
"You must be a fairy."
"I am a fairy.
Sorry, that's just something I never thought
I would say."
The series is centered around the teen-aged
Bloom, a fairy raised by humans and sent to
the Alfea school so she can learn the ways
of fairies, and also to control her dangerous
magical abilities.
And if Abigail Cowen looks familiar to you,
it's likely because you're a fan of teen dramas
with an adult bent.
As it happens, another series which Cowen
appeared in also turned some heads for its
slightly twisted take on considerably tamer
source material.
That series was Chilling Adventures of Sabrina,
which told the tale of a teenage girl as she
nobly, and sometimes not-so nobly, struggled
to balance her everyday life amongst humans
with her more exciting life as a witch, who
just so happens to worship at the altar of
a certain dark lord.
Essentially posited as a classic teen drama
with heaping doses of magical mirth, gory
horror movie camp, and some seriously sinister
action, Chilling Adventures of Sabrina debuted
on Netflix to great reviews in 2018, and has
just wrapped an equally lauded four season
run on the platform.
Cowen appeared in three of those seasons as
one of the Weird Sisters, a trio who frequently
tormented and occasionally teamed up with
Sabrina.
If you're wondering why Cowen didn't appear
in all four seasons of the supernatural series,
it's because her character Dorcas tragically
didn't survive the third, having been turned
to stone, then later killed.
Needless to say, the Weird Sisters were never
really the same after Dorcas' death.
Likewise, Cowen's presence was sorely missed
throughout Sabrina's wonderful fourth season.
Although, Dorcas fans were treated to a brief
resurrection during one emotional episode.
"I'm back, Prudence.
Yes, yes I see that."
If you haven't had a chance to watch Chilling
Adventures of Sabrina just yet, it's still
entirely likely you noticed Cowen's face on
Netflix before her roles as Dorcas and Bloom,
though you would have had to do so through
a waft of wavy eighties hair.
You also would have needed to keep an exceedingly
sharp eye out for her ginger locks, as Cowen
made only a couple of brief appearances in
the troubled town of Hawkins, Indiana.
That's right, Stranger Things fans: one of
Cowen's first appearances came in the second
season of Netflix's sci-fi sensation.
Cowen actually appeared in two episodes, but
there's little question she made a far bigger
impact in the first.
And as far as that first appearance goes,
it came in the season 2 premiere, round about
the time bad boy extraordinaire Billy Hargrove
made his infamous first trip through the parking
lot of Hawkins High School.
As you might recall, a small group of Hawkins
girls watch the chain-smoking hard rocker
as he walks, commenting on his ... ahem, posterior
region.
Cowen was one of those gawking girls.
And while we don't learn much about her character,
Vicki, we do know she had at least a fleeting
encounter with Hawkins' baddest of bad boys,
as she's seen leaving school with him a couple
episodes later.
She was never again spotted in Hawkins High
though, possibly because Cowen moved on to
bigger roles, like in Sabrina.
Whatever the case the may be, it's nice to
see Abigail Cowen is continuing her already
fruitful relationship with Netflix: The streamer
is reportedly eyeing a second season of Fate:
The Winx Saga after it debuted at #1 on their
coveted Top 10 chart.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
Netflix shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.